the NFL Players Association has been
averse to expanding the NFL's regular
season from 16 to 18 games that is now a
thing again it had gone away the NFL
realized and Chris this dates back I
think to six seven eight years ago the
Commissioner was routinely trashing the
quality of the NFL's preseason because
the idea was hey we shrink the preseason
we expand the regular-season that's what
the end game has always been the
preseason stinks well what do we do with
these two extra games that we get rid of
hey I got an idea let's play them in the
regular season and that dates back to
when the NFL expanded the Ross or the
schedule rather from 14 to 16 games in
the late 70s they used to play six
preseason games now they play four it's
20 total games it's been a very simple
and logical mindset for the NFL but the
push toward making the game safer you
can't reconcile that with more
regular-season games well the time has
come apparently for the NFL to try mark
masky The Washington Post reports that
the NFL could be pushing for 16 to 18
regular season games a two-game increase
in this current labor negotiation I
still don't believe the NFL PA is gonna
go for it Chris it's going to take
something big far bigger than getting
rid of the marijuana prohibition far
bigger than revamping the personal
conduct policy it's going to take
something significant to get the players
to go along with two extra
regular-season games because it is
abundantly clear Chris
they don't want two extra regular-season
games no I mean I can't see how they
would you know first of all at this just
to start here the four preseason games
are very necessary right now in the NFL
with the proximity to the practice
restrictions and limitations on hitting
you know yeah okay and Tom Brady Aaron
Rodgers Khalil Mack they don't need four
preseason games but the rest of the
football does these young guys you're
trying to develop that's an important
time for them I would also wonder 18
games season so what they're gonna start
the season in August mid-august is that
how they're gonna do it there I just
would like to understand the logistics
of that no yeah guys they want to push
they want what do they desperately want
to get the Super Bowl on President's Day
weekend so
together still start the weekend right
after Labor Day and push it through to
Presidents Day so well you know but
because one thing that people always ask
for move the Super Bowl to Saturday so I
don't have to worry about working the
next day hey perfect alternative you
play it on a three day weekend people
don't have to worry about working on
Monday the most part and then you have
the Super Bowl that Sunday that's what
they'd like to do so it wouldn't start
in August it would start when it always
does if we just extend deeper into
febrile of that I mean first of all I
think the Monday after the Super Bowl
should be a national holiday I really
think we've got to that point in this
country so I actually like that aspect
of it but I don't necessarily like 18
games no I don't we're having a hard
enough time fine you know we can finding
a full team at full strength and the
16-game season you know that was one of
the things I know I said in the first
hour but yeah we got a lot of teams who
limp into the playoffs every year so
also it is hypocritical if the NFL wants
to talk about player safety and then all
of a sudden just go yeah but we want you
to kill each other
two more weeks of the year and the most
physical sport in the planet so I don't
like that either
I would think major concessions have to
be made because this is major money
major TV money you mentioned it it's
major gambling money it's two more weeks
of the whole country gambling on every
damn game in the NFL that's big-time so
I understand why the NFL wants it but
you know like I said they're gonna have
to really I think make a major major
concession to the players to get this
done do you think that all these changes
they've been making in an effort to make
the game safer do you think at some
point they're gonna say hey look at
everything we've done to make the game
safer most recently No More Oklahoma
drills and they say they do it so these
safety measures will trickle down to the
lower levels of the sport but at some
point maybe they could say things are a
lot different than they used to be
playing 18 regular season games isn't as
big of a safety risk as it used to be do
you think they're trying to set that up
I do think they're trying to set that up
I guess what I'd have to see maybe maybe
some numbers on on that too it's about
you know where the game is going safety
wise and I know it's going in the right
direction so if they can continue to
prove that guys are staying healthier
and
you know maybe there's not you know the
effects that there might have been
playing football in the 80s and 90s
whatever it may be yeah it seems like
you know again they're trying to make
the sport cleaner safer better to watch
better for young kids to play growing up
know bad examples by you know spearing
pyres or doing anything like that and I
get it and it's great but it's still an
incredibly incredibly physical sport as
physical as ever because of the specific
training of players and all they've done
is you know play defensive end since
they were a freshman in high school and
that's all they've worked at and eaten
and that's all they do
they're consumed to that and that's
where the game has become different than
maybe 25 30 years ago one idea that's
been lingering for the past several
years the notion of expanding to 18
regular season games but limiting each
players participation per season to 16
games that would force coaches to decide
which week we sit guys down now there
would be exemptions for kickers and
punters and long snappers and holders
and quarterbacks I put quarterbacks are
protecting more than other players yeah
how can how can you play a game without
your starting quarterback but would that
be sigh you know that that's up I know
there are people in the league who are
fascinated by that concept now you know
a lot of players naturally miss games
during a season anyway because of injury
and I think a lot of the tough decisions
that a coach would have to make will be
taken care of by you know that we're all
the running back to missing this week's
game well that's one less game we have
to worry about when we would identify
which week we're gonna put him on the
bench but that is something that gives
the NFL what it wants and it addresses
the safety concern at least on the
surface by saying hey you're not gonna
play more than 16 games do you think
that would go over with the Union gosh I
mean maybe I guess you know and the
first thing that comes that says just be
tremendously hard to juggle rosters like
that you know I mean you're right
there's injuries and guys miss you know
game or two here all throughout the
season but you know III you know I just
find it yo ok this is a week this
offensive lineman's supposed to not play
cuz he's played 15 games already and
then you know you go through the week of
practice and all of a sudden somebody
gets hurt and you're going oh my gosh we
gotta sign more play I don't know how
that would work that seems like it would
be very hard to me and to be very
stressful and tough on organism
to have to do that balancing act through
the season you know do they add another
bye week to the year with 18 games is
that enough no they don't want one that
would that would screw up that count
yeah right that would and and and look
I'm glad you mentioned the bye week
because another alternative that has
been thrown out there is the idea of
adding a bye weekend going to 17 not 18
okay actually like seven I can deal with
do anything right but because because it
look it I don't like eight and eight hey
let's eight Nate it's a tie I want eight
and seven or seven and eight or more
accurately if we'd have 17 games it'll
be nine and eight or eight nine unless
somebody goes eight eight and one
everyone's either gonna have a winning
record or a losing record and there's
something that's just viscerally
appealing about that Plus with those 16
extra games that come from playing a 17
game season those are 16 games it can be
played on a neutral site and you don't
have to worry about people giving up
home games
everybody's got eight home games and
everybody plays one neutral site game
and you can play neutral site games in
London in Mexico in Canada wherever and
you can also play some neutral site
games in the United States at oh I don't
know Ann Arbor or at the the South Bend
Notre Dame Stadium or a Penn State
Stadium you can do all sorts of creative
things with those 16 extra games that
are all played on a neutral site and and
I think that's what and maybe they're
maybe they're pushing 18 with the idea
of getting so it's time to negotiate
we'll take 17 III mean again it's not a
bad idea I like some of the some of the
things you said there I really do I mean
I forgot what I was gonna actually
question you about there but I don't
know where I was gonna go with it and
now I've totally blanked out because I'm
trying to search it in my brain and I
can't remember exactly what I was gonna
say to peel back the curtain control
room please please clip that I mean I
can use any time I want any time he's
giving me a hard time we'll play that
back here's another angle because as it
relates to the concession it would take
the marijuana policy making that go away
that players aren't players are not
going to fall for that the players are
gonna want something significant if this
is going to happen a bigger piece of the
pie they're going to want expanded
rosters I think that's a given I think
you do put in play some of the things
that maybe would be pie in the sky
players like getting rid of the
franchise tag or shortening the
contracts that players sign when they
come out of college maybe they're all
three years instead of four years there
there are a lot of major concessions if
you're willing to do this and I credit
the NFLPA for taking such a hard line
against 18 games all these years it
shows how valuable it is to get the
players to agree and the players are
smart on this because it is extremely
valuable to the league to add those two
extra weeks if you can take the money
that is paid for 17 weekends of football
and add two more to make it 19 weekends
and push the Super Bowl into Presidents
Day weekend and everything gets bigger
and everything gets more profitable I
think that that there is a willingness
at some level if the league really wants
it to make a major concession that would
that the players could look at and say
how can we say no to 18 regular-season
games if this is what they're off yeah I
mean III hear you and maybe they will
make an offer to where the players just
go okay we can't say no to this but I
still worry about the injury rate I mean
it's hard enough to get through the year
16 games as is and then if you talk
about the guys that got to get into the
playoffs also does 18 games you know
you're getting more chances to for the
big-time stars to get hurt which also
can hurt the playoffs you know are the
players gonna be too worn down for the
time of the year where we want to see
the best quality football which is the
playoffs two more games to the list I
don't know if you're gonna necessarily
necessarily see the best football there
there has to be offered so that would be
other my concerns as a player you know
come late January and things like that
whoo I mean I just don't know if
everybody realizes the struggle the
body's got to go through at that point
you know after 20-something weeks of
legit football contact hard rigorous
workouts on a daily basis all that that
would be my concerns this is what I
wanted to say before and I blanked out
and I'm sorry the odd scheduled thing is
interesting that yeah that's an
interesting point there's no sport that
I know of that has an odd number of
games or there's their season right am I
wrong about that
I mean it's 82 for a basketball it's 162
for saw baseball hockey I believes 82 as
well right - yeah so I
it is an interesting point you brought
up there that's where I got flustered in
my brain sorry I forgot that before well
and here's one last point before we take
a break no matter what the new structure
would be if they do make a change if
it's 17 if it's 18 if it's 18 with a
limit that each player can only play in
16 the new reality is something that
Bill Belichick will figure out before
anyone else and just continue to crack
the code and set the agenda and figure
out exactly how to work within the new
reality and get the most out of it so
get ready for that as well no matter how
they move things around that Belichick
is gonna be the first one to figure out
how to use it all to his advantage we're
gonna take a break when we return time
to go up to number 35 on the list of
Chris Simms quarterbacks for 2019 we'll
be back right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports